Andrew Carnegie: Robber Baron or America’s
Greatest Philanthropist?
When it comes to judging a person by their
legacy, things are seldom black or white.
In other words, few people can be considered
purely good or unequivocally evil.
Andrew Carnegie was a man of paradoxes. He
was a businessman, first and foremost, and,
oftentimes, this meant that someone else had
to pay the price when he made his fortunes.
Although publicly he championed the welfare
of his employees, the working conditions in
his many factories and plants didn’t exactly
match up with his touted values.
On the other hand, Carnegie donated almost
his entire wealth to humanitarian causes,
not to mention the fact that his actions set
the trend for all the other billionaire philanthropists
who followed. Therefore, it is up to you to
decide where exactly his legacy sits as today
we take a look at the life of industrialist
Andrew Carnegie.
Early Years
Right off the bat, we should have a quick
talk about Andrew Carnegie’s last name and
the fact that most people pronounce it wrong.
As a spokeswoman for the Carnegie Corporation
of New York specifies, he was Scottish so
the correct pronunciation of his name is car-NAY-gee,
not CAR-ne-gee, as most people say it.
Now that we got that out of the way, let’s
look at Carnegie’s early years. He was born
on November 25, 1835, in the town of Dunfermline
in the Scottish county of Fife, to William
and Margaret Carnegie. He had a younger brother
named Thomas who would go on to play a vital
role in the family’s business interests
until he died of pneumonia at just 43 years
of age.
Carnegie had a modest upbringing as his father
was a hand-loom weaver. His first home consisted
of just one main room inside a cottage which
the Carnegies shared with another family.
At the time of Andrew’s birth, Dunfermline
was quite famous for its production of high-quality
linen. This created a high demand for Will
Carnegie’s services which allowed the family
a brief respite from poverty, enough that
they were able to move to a larger house.
This didn’t last long, though, and, in fact,
things soon became worse than ever. The Industrial
Revolution brought with it steam-powered looms
which made hand weavers like Will Carnegie
obsolete.
During the 1840s, Andrew’s father joined
Chartism, a political movement which sought
to improve conditions for the working class.
The main goal of Chartists was to obtain universal
manhood suffrage - all men would have the
right to vote which, theoretically, would
allow the masses to take over the government
from the aristocracy. Will and his father-in-law,
Thomas Morrison, actually became quite prominent
members and were heads of the Chartist chapter
in Dunfermline. Regardless, the movement was
struck down in Parliament and, eventually,
faded away. It makes it even stranger that
Carnegie would go on to crush unionizing efforts
later in life given that his own father campaigned
hard for better worker conditions.
In 1848, there were few prospects left for
the Carnegie family in Scotland. Margaret
Carnegie heard tales of a better life in America
from her sister who already moved there. The
family sold all their possessions and secured
a loan to book passage on a ship from Glasgow
to New York City. It was a long, miserable
trip where the poor passengers were packed
in the cargo hold like sardines. Those who
did not become sick from the terrible conditions
had to work on deck as the ship’s crew was
undermanned.
But the voyage ultimately ended successfully.
There was no immigration station on Ellis
Island yet, so the ship disembarked somewhere
in lower Manhattan and the Carnegies continued
their trip west until they reached their final
destination of Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
Life in America
The Carnegie family settled in Allegheny City,
a municipality next to Pittsburgh which would
get annexed a few decades later. Thirteen-year-old
Andrew needed a job and he found one as a
bobbin boy at the same cotton mill where his
father was employed. He had to work from sunup
to sundown and made just one dollar and twenty
cents per week, but Carnegie later said in
his autobiography that none of the millions
he made later “gave [him] such happiness
as [his] first week’s earnings.” He was
now a breadwinner for the family.
Carnegie soon moved on to a new job at a bobbins
manufacturer where he made two dollars a week.
He then became the boss’s clerk because
he had nice handwriting. Later, his uncle
found him a better job as a messenger boy
for the telegraph service which paid two dollars
fifty per week.
Working as a messenger allowed Carnegie to
meet many of Pittsburgh’s most influential
people who often received urgent news from
outside the city. Andrew excelled at his job
so he was promoted to telegraph operator a
few years later. In 1853, Carnegie made another
career switch and went to work as a clerk
and operator for Thomas A. Scott who was then
a superintendent with Pennsylvania Railroad
but will later become the president of the
entire company.
The next few years saw ups and downs for Carnegie.
His father passed away but, in 1859, he was
promoted to superintendent when his mentor,
Thomas Scott, became vice-president of the
Pennsylvania Railroad Company. He now had
a salary of $1,500 a year. Scott clearly took
a liking to Carnegie who he referred to as
“my boy Andy” and not only taught him
the ins and outs of business, but also enabled
him to make some serious money for the first
time.
One day, Scott approached Carnegie and asked
him if he had $500 to buy ten shares of Adams
Express stock because it would provide him
with a nice return. This information was,
of course, obtained through insider trading,
but they weren’t that fussed about it back
then. Carnegie didn’t have anywhere near
that sum, but his mother mortgaged the family
home and he made his first investment. Soon
afterwards, he received an envelope addressed
to “Andrew Carnegie, Esquire” from the
Gold Exchange Bank of New York. It contained
a check for ten dollars, representing the
monthly dividend on his investment. It was
the first time that Carnegie made any money
without having to work manual labor for it.
He saw that check as the “goose that lays
the golden eggs.”
Carnegie became involved in more business
ventures, most of them railroad-related. He
met with Theodore T. Woodruff, the man who
invented the sleeping car. He was impressed
with the design and brought it to the attention
of Scott and the Pennsylvania Railroad Company’s
president, John Edgar Thomson. As a reward,
Woodruff offered him an eighth interest in
the venture.
Business during the Civil War
During the American Civil War, Thomas Scott
was first appointed as Colonel of Volunteers
and then Assistant Secretary of War. Carnegie,
of course, was right there behind him as his
second-in-command. His main duty was to ensure
that the railroads and telegraph system were
maintained in working order for the Union
Army.
At the outset of the war, Carnegie took a
trip to inspect the main telegraph line to
Washington. At some distance from the capital,
he noticed a few wires which had been pinned
down to the ground using wooden stakes. He
went to remove the stakes, not realizing that
the wires had been pulled to one side prior
to being pinned and were taut. They flung
upwards violently, hitting Carnegie in the
face and cutting a huge gash on his cheek.
He later joked that he was among the first
to “shed [his] blood for [his] country.”
During this time, Carnegie got the opportunity
to meet President Abraham Lincoln and many
members of his cabinet. He later wrote with
great esteem about Lincoln whom he considered
an “extraordinary man.” He mentioned that
the president always had a kind word for everybody,
even the youngest messenger boys. Carnegie
described Lincoln as one of the “most homely
men” he ever saw when his features were
in repose, but that when animated, “intellect
shone through his eyes...to a degree...never
seen in any other.”
A Man of Industry
Just because he
was
involved with the war did not mean that Carnegie
stopped looking for new business ventures.
If anything, this new experience revealed
to him the industries which he believed would
flourish in the years and decades to come.
First, he invested in an oil company at the
right time and this quickly yielded huge returns
for him which provided Carnegie the capital
needed to start his own enterprises.
The up-and-coming industrialist correctly
predicted that the demand for railroads would
only increase and he wanted to be there to
meet those demands. First, in 1864, he founded
the Superior Rail Mill and Blast Furnaces,
a company that manufactured rails. Soon afterwards
came the Pittsburgh Locomotive Works which
built, you guessed it, locomotives.
Even though Carnegie had a high-paying job
with the Pennsylvania Railroad Company and
the favor of his superiors, he decided it
was time to leave after the war and strike
it out on his own. He remained on good terms
with them, though, and secured many lucrative
contracts in the years to follow.
In 1865, Andrew Carnegie founded the Keystone
Bridge Company, with his brother Thomas serving
as treasurer. It was followed by several ironworks
and plants. Steel was the way of the future
in Carnegie’s mind and, indeed, would become
responsible for the bulk of his vast fortune.
Again having a keen attentiveness for the
future, Carnegie was an early adopter of the
Bessemer process, a new way of refining steel
from molten pig iron. It was cheap and efficient
and allowed for the mass production of steel
on a scale never seen before. Carnegie invested
heavily in this technique and it paid off
big for him as he became the dominant force
in the American steel industry. He also prioritized
vertical integration to make sure that he
controlled companies responsible for all aspects
of his steel business such as supplying raw
materials and transporting finished goods.
The Billion Dollar Corporation
The steel business made Andrew Carnegie one
of the richest men in the world. Of course,
there were others who looked on at his steel
empire with covetous eyes. One of those men
was financier and banker John Pierpont Morgan.
In 1898, he bought and merged several steel
producers to form the Federal Steel Company
which, by 1900, became America’s second-largest
manufacturer of steel (behind Carnegie’s
company, of course).
But second place was not good enough for J.
P. Morgan. A war was brewing between the two
corporations and Carnegie knew it. The Scotsman
believed he could weather the storm and successfully
drive off the competition. On the other hand,
Carnegie was not a young man anymore, and
had already been contemplating retirement
for a while now.
The lynchpin in this business venture was
Charles M. Schwab, a high-ranking executive
and trusted advisor of Carnegie. He was first
approached by Morgan who preferred an alliance
over a war and then convinced Carnegie to
accept a buyout for his company. The asking
price was $480 million for Carnegie Steel,
a term which Morgan accepted on the spot with
no negotiation. Later, while talking to Carnegie,
the financier half-jokingly said he would
have paid another $100 million.
The deal was done in 1901 and Carnegie personally
gained around $230 million from the sale of
his company. J. P. Morgan went on to buy several
other businesses and merged them all together
to form U.S. Steel, the first billion-dollar
corporation in the world.
Personal High Points and Heartbreaks
Carnegie’s career might have been full of
twists and turns, but his personal life was
decidedly less exciting. He was a bachelor
for most of his life, allegedly due to his
relationship with his mother to whom he was
completely devoted. When Carnegie moved his
headquarters to New York City, the two shared
a suite at the Windsor Hotel.
Even so, during the 1880s, Carnegie made the
acquaintance of Louise Whitfield, a woman
who was 21 years younger than him. The industrialist
noted in his autobiography that, the more
time they spent together, the more he realized
that Louise was “the perfect one beyond
any [he] had met” and all other young women
he knew “faded into ordinary beings.”
Curiously, Carnegie believed that his vast
fortune worked against him as Louise thought
he already had everything in the world while
she would have preferred to be the companion
and constant supporter of a struggling man,
mimicking the relationship of her parents.
The year 1886 proved to be devastating for
Carnegie. Both his mother and his brother
died within days of each other, while Carnegie
himself was struggling at death’s door with
typhoid fever. Eventually, he managed to recover
and Louise’s company became the only “ray
of hope and comfort” in his life. She now
realized that Carnegie needed her more than
any other man and she became his “helpmeet”
as he described her. The two married on April
22, 1887, and went on to have only one child
- a girl named Margaret born ten years later.
The Johnstown Flood
As is usually the case with wealthy businessmen,
Andrew Carnegie’s life was not devoid of
controversies. After his brother Thomas died,
many of his duties were taken on by Henry
Clay Frick, another industrialist who first
founded his own coke manufacturing company
and later became chairman of Carnegie Steel.
It seems that Frick was at the center of all
the major scandals which tainted Carnegie’s
reputation. First was the time when he and
his associates caused one of the deadliest
floods in American history.
During the early 1880s, Frick founded the
South Fork Fishing and Hunting Club. It counted
between 50 and 60 members who included industrialists,
bankers, attorneys, and almost all other prominent
men in Pennsylvania. Unsurprisingly, Andrew
Carnegie was one of them.
At first, the club seemed rather innocuous.
It was just another place where rich guys
could relax, smoke some cigars and maybe do
some fishing. However, they wanted their own
private place where they would not be disturbed.
To that end, they purchased the South Fork
Dam on Lake Conemaugh.
The dam was originally built by the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania a few decades prior, but it
had since been abandoned and switched ownership
multiple times. When the South Fork Club made
the purchase, it was still functional, but
in a state of disrepair due to neglect and
the fact that a previous owner removed parts
to sell for scrap metal.
The club arranged for modifications to the
dam, but they were more concerned with making
it suit their needs rather than making it
safe - they added a fish screen to the spillway,
they leveled off the top to make room for
a road and, most importantly, they lowered
the dam by several feet. Whenever the dam
sprung a leak, it was quickly patched up and
forgotten about.
It was just a matter of time before disaster
struck. That moment happened on May 31, 1889.
The area had been hit by one of the most powerful
storms ever recorded in the region which saw
between 6 and 10 inches of rainfall in 24
hours. That morning, the club manager saw
that the lake had swollen and was ready to
tip over the dam. He gathered some workers
in a desperate attempt to unclog the spillway
which had been blocked by debris caught in
the fish screen. Their efforts proved in vain.
Shortly before 3 p.m., the dam breached, sending
over 3.8 billion gallons of water to the towns
below.
South Fork was the first hit, but got off
easy because it was on high ground. Several
towns were affected, but Johnstown was completely
devastated in what was, at the time, the single
greatest loss of life in American history.
According to the Johnstown Area Heritage Association,
2,209 people were killed, including 400 children.
Their bodies were washed away as far as Cincinnati,
400 miles away.
For the South Fork Fishing and Hunting Club,
the main priority was negating any liability
on their part. They used all the money and
influence at their disposal and ensured that
none of them were ever held accountable by
successfully arguing that it was an “act
of God.” People tried to sue them, but they
all lost in court.
We can’t say with any certainty how much
of the blame should be put on Carnegie personally.
He was simply the most prominent member of
the club, but that doesn’t mean he was involved
with the maintenance of the dam. Even so,
he, like all the other members, agreed to
sweep the whole thing under the rug and made
no further mention of the flood or the club,
not even in his own autobiography.
A recent study from the University of Pittsburgh
at Johnstown confirmed what many suspected
all along - it was the modifications made
by the club which caused the dam to fail,
not the heavy rainfall.
The Homestead Strike
Throughout his career, Carnegie liked to portray
himself as a fair employer who looked after
the rights and wellbeing of his workers, but
he didn’t always practice what he preached.
At no time was this more evident than in 1892
during the Homestead strike.
On one side, we had the Homestead Steel Works,
part of Carnegie’s steel empire. On the
other, there was the Amalgamated Association
of Iron and Steel Workers or AA, the most
powerful labor union at the time.
The workers organized a strike after their
last deal ended to negotiate a wage increase.
Henry Clay Frick, who was in charge of operations
at the plant, wanted the exact opposite - he
intended to slash their wages and, more importantly,
break up the union.
The situation unfolded exactly like many other
labor disputes of that time. The union went
on strike. The company brought in non-union
workers and called in over three hundred Pinkerton
agents who acted as muscle. Eventually, things
escalated to violence and around ten men were
killed and dozens more injured. In the end,
the state militia intervened and the town
was placed under martial law.
The situation took an unexpected turn on July
23 when a prominent anarchist named Alexander
Berkman tried to assassinate Henry Frick in
his office in downtown Pittsburgh. Berkman
shot Frick twice and then stabbed him in the
legs several times. Despite this, Frick survived
and Berkman was arrested.
Although the anarchist had no ties to the
AA, his actions generated sympathy for Frick
and turned public opinion against the union.
Consequently, other employers refused to hire
AA workers. Their membership numbers collapsed
and their funds dried out. The strike ended
with a huge victory for the industrialists.
Like with the Johnstown flood, it is a matter
of debate how much blame can be placed on
Carnegie. He was in Scotland during the most
violent days of the strike. In his autobiography,
he claimed ignorance of the matter, saying
that nothing else “wounded [him] so deeply”
and calling it the biggest regret of his business
career. However, other documents suggest that
he was well-aware of Frick’s actions and
gave him approval to do whatever was necessary,
writing him in a letter that “we are with
you to the end.”
Philanthropy
“The man who dies rich, dies disgraced.”
Those were the words of Andrew Carnegie, expressing
his belief that it was the responsibility
of the wealthy to use all their extra money
for the betterment of society. He made this
clear in 1889 when he published an article
titled “The Gospel of Wealth”, where he
outlined his views. Carnegie was against simply
passing down the fortune to heirs because,
in his experience, these heirs were often
self-indulgent or irresponsible.
In this regard, the Scottish industrialist
put his money where his mouth was. By the
time he died in 1919 of bronchial pneumonia,
the 83-year-old businessman had given away
over $350 million of his personal fortune.
He was still a rich man when he died so, technically,
according to his own words, he died disgraced,
but he made provisions so that the rest of
his wealth would go to worthy causes. His
family kept the property and a small trust
to live comfortably, but other than that,
everything else was given away.
As a self-made man, Carnegie wasn’t a big
fan of charities for two reasons. First, he
did not trust that those charities would manage
his money well and, second, he believed that
by just giving money directly to people, you
did not enable them to actually improve their
station in life.
Carnegie’s biggest passion was education.
He set up 3,000 public libraries in cities
all over the United States, Britain, and Canada,
starting in 1883 with his hometown of Dunfermline.
Many other institutions received generous
grants such as various trusts and universities.
The Carnegie Corporation of New York received
the largest gift of $125 million and they
still do philanthropic work in Carnegie’s
name today.
Do all these donations make up for Carnegie’s
plutocratic policies? Is that why he did it
in the first place, to help ease his conscience?
These are questions we couldn’t possibly
answer, but we do know that the actions of
Andrew Carnegie set him apart and made him
unique among the ruthless industrialists of
the 19th century.